>> Sean: TONIGHT CHICAGO POLICE
ARE IDENTIFYING THE HERO OFFICER
KILLED IN A TRAFFIC STOP OVER
THE WEEKEND.
HER NAME, ELLA FRENCH.
I DOUBT YOU KNOW HER NAME OR ANY
OF THE NEARLY 150 POLICE
OFFICERS KILLED IN THE LINE OF
DUTY SO FAR THIS YEAR ALONE.
29 YEARS OLD.
JOINED THE DEPARTMENT IN 2018.
HER BROTHER CALLED HER THE
EPITOME OF A GOOD SAMARITAN IN
AN INTERVIEW WITH THE CHICAGO
TRIBUNE.
A SECOND OFFICER CRITICALLY
INJURED IN THE SHOOTING.
OVER THE WEEKEND, CHICAGO POLICE
GATHERED AT THE HOSPITAL.
THEY TURNED THEIR BACKS ON THE
FAILED FAR LEFT MAYOR LORI
LIGHTWEIGHT THAT RENEWSES TO
TAKE THIS VIOLENCE SERIOUSLY AND
REFUSING TO TAKE SECURITY STEPS
IN CHICAGO.
NOW CHARGES HAVE BEEN FILED
AGAINST TWO BROTHERS IN
CONNECTION WITH THE FATAL
SHOOTING.
HERE WITH REACTION, LEO 2.0
TERRELL AND RAYMOND LOPEZ IS
WITH US HERE, ALDERMAN IN
CHICAGO.
HOW DO WE HAVE NUMBERS LIKE THIS
EVERY WEEKEND, YOU DON'T HEAR
ABOUT THE PEOPLE'S NAMES ANT IT
CONTINUES?
HOW DOES IT KEEP CONTINUING WEEK
AFTER WEEK?
I DON'T WANT TO REPORT ON THIS
ANYMORE.
I'M TIRED OF REPORTING ON
INNOCENT PEOPLE GETTING SHOT AND
KILLED.
>> I'D LOVE TO TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING POSITIVE ONE DAY, SEAN
ABOUT THE CITY OF CHICAGO.
WE'VE HAD 38 OFFICERS SHOT AT
SINCE LORI LIGHTFOOT HAS BEEN
MAYOR THIS YEAR ALONE.
WE HAD ELLA FRENCH THAT WAS
MURDERED THIS PAST WEEKEND.
THE ONLY THING MORE DANGEROUS
THAN THE GANG BANGERS AND
CRIMINALS ON THE STREETS IS
MAYOR LIGHTFOOT AND HER FAILED
BELIEF THAT SHE'S IN CHARGE AND
HELPING THE CITY OF CHICAGO.
SHE'S AN ABSOLUTE FAILURE.
IT'S TIME THAT WE HAVE
DISCUSSIONS ON WHETHER OR NOT
SHE NEEDS TO STEP ASIDE.
SHE'S CLEARLY UNABLE TO PROTECT
THE PEOPLE OR THE POLICE IN THE
CITY OF CHICAGO.
>> Sean: IN FAIRNESS, ROMBO DEAD
FISH SAME THING, THIS WOMAN IS
29 YEARS OLD.
73 PEOPLE SHOT THIS WEEKEND.
WE DON'T KNOW THEIR NAMES, DO
WE, LEO?
>> NO, WE WON'T KNOW THEIR NAMES
BECAUSE THEY DON'T FOCUS ON THE
VICTIM.
I WANT TO SAY BRAVO TO THE
OFFICERS.
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT GOING TO
BE USED AS A PHOTO OPEN.
I'M GLAD YOU SHUNNED LORI
LIGHTFOOT.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT LORI
LIGHTFOOT DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
POLICE OFFICERS.
THEY WERE BEING USED AND THEY
TURNED THEIR BACK ON HER.
SHE'S BEEN A NONSUPPORTER OF
POLICE OFFICERS.
HER SPEECH WAS NOTHING MORE THAN
SNAKE OIL.
SHE'S A FRAUD.
SHE DOESN'T SUPPORT POLICE.
NO POLICE OFFICER IN CHICAGO
SHOULD LOOK AT HER.
THEY SHOULD ALWAYS TAKE THEIR
BACK ON HER.
>> TWO YEARS SHE'S VILLIFIED THE
POLICE.
FOR TWO YEARS SHE'S VILLIFIED
THE POLICE.
NOW SHE SAYS DIVISIVE RHETORIC
MUST STOP.
SHE'S FUELED IT TIME AND TIME
AGAIN.
SHE BROUGHT US TO THIS POINT.
>> 29 YEARS OLD.
>> YOU SHOULD RUN AGAINST HER.
IF YOU'RE SERIOUS, YOU SHOULD
RUN AGAINST HER AND SUPPORT THE
POLICE.
IF YOU SUPPORT THE POLICE, BILL
DOWN THERE.
>> Sean: LEO, WE NEED SOMEBODY
TO STOP THIS.
>> I'LL SUPPORT YOU.
>> SEAN, I'LL SAY THIS.
I'M COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT
SHE DOESN'T GET A SECOND TURN.
MY CITY CANNOT AFFORD TWO TERMS
OF LORI LIGHTFOOT.
>> Sean: CHICAGO, 73 PEOPLE A
29-YEAR-OLD COP I